Hey everyone!
No math here, I just wanted to post two quick
announcements for you.
First, the number of you who have opted to
subscribe to this channel has once again rolled
over a power of 2, which is just mind-boggling
to me.
I’m still touched that there’s so many
of you who enjoy math like this, just for
fun, and who have helped support the channel
by watching, by sharing the content here,
and for many of you on Patreon, very directly
supporting it.
Really, each one of the 2^19 of you means
a lot to me.
As a thanks, and just for fun, I’ll be doing
a second Q&A session.
I’ve left a link to where you can ask and
upvote questions on the screen here and in
the description, and just like with the first
one I’ll answer the questions in the podcast
I do with Ben Eater and Ben Stenhuag, since
I think discussions are more fun than answers
in a vacuum.
By the way, if you guys don’t already know
about Ben Eater’s channel, what are ya’
doing!
This man is the Bob Ross of computer engineering.
If you want to understand how a computer works,
and I mean really understand it from the ground
up, his channel is the place to go.
Trust me, he is a very good explainer.
Anyway, the reason I bring him up is that
he and I just recorded a pretty interesting
conversation about Net Neutrality.
I want to be very clear: Ben Eater is not
against net neutrality, and nor am I.
However, the issue is a lot more nuanced than
I first realized.
And because there are already many great videos
about Net Neutrality, and why it’s a good
thing, to offer content you may not have seen
before this conversation was a chance to unearth
some of the tradeoffs at play here.
You see, the thing about Eater is that before
he was creating educational content, he worked
for many years in the networking industry,
so he has a pretty clear view of both sides
of this equation.
I’m going to play you just a minute of it
here, and then link to the full video if you
want to go see it on Ben’s channel, which
you should be going to check out anyway.
For those of you who would prefer to listen
to a 45-minute conversation in podcast form,
we did also publish it as an episode
of Ben, Ben, and Blue.